when you've been wounded or when you've
been hurt the natural defense is i don't
want to go there anymore that is painful
and so the narrative that comes out is i
don't need anyone and that is a form of
protection it is very lonely on that
side of the coin
jessica palm welcome to the show
thank you for having me
you are a relationship expert so
given that this is the week that love
island is restarting in the uk i wanted
to speak to you about something that i
noticed online i thought was quite
interesting so there's a student news
publication called the tab
and they've got a trash page which is
kind of celebrity gossip and sort of
trashy news and stuff like that they put
a tweet out the other day that said the
love island promo pics are always so bad
so he is actually what the love island
is from 2022 look like in real life
so what they were saying is that the
promo pictures that are done by an
entire team a huge team right there's a
hair and makeup army there's stylists
there's professional lighting there's a
guy with a huge long lens dslr and it's
not like they just take one they take
tons and tons of photos on this photo
shoot
and they had a problem with the fact
that
those were unrepresentative and what
they were using as the benchmark for why
it was unrepresentative
were their instagram photos
so they went on and said look at them on
instagram and then look at what they're
doing so if you dig into the actual
article it says
there is one simple fact on this earth
and that is that the love island
photographer always does everyone so
dirty year after year it never changes
and the promo pics get if anything worse
so ahead of the launch next week of love
island 2022 here's everything you need
to know about the new islanders their
instagram handles ages jobs and what
they actually look like in real life so
what we've done now is we've entered a
world where the hyper real has become
more real than reality so photos from
instagram which is a social media
platform
known for enhanced and airbrushed images
is being used as the benchmark against
which everything else should be measured
instagram is what the cast actually look
like in real life despite the fact it's
taken by this huge army of of people
that are behind the uk's biggest reality
tv show they're doing them so dirty so i
think it's it was just really
interesting to me that kind of the bar
stool's been turned upside down that
people are so used to spending time
online with others
that they see the online world
as more accurate than the physical one
and the closer that we can fit real life
to a digital existence the more
comfortable people feel
yeah that's very interesting especially
because usually on instagram everything
is filtered and so orchestrated that
you're not really getting
the reality of the person but that's
what they see they're like look this is
what people really look like in real
life
and somehow these photos and videos
remember they do this huge big
intro
hi my name's jessica i'm 19 and a
hairdresser from wigan or whatever
wha like what what are you trying to say
you're trying to say that somehow the
instagram is more real
than the photos and the videos that have
been taken and that
they should be retrofitted
to make people feel more comfortable or
to better represent the real them which
comes from instagram it just seems so
backwards like the most
blatant
social media
life
representation that i think i've ever
seen and this is the lead up to love
island which is in the uk is kind of
like a
uh
i guess a national ritual now i did the
first season i was the first person
through the doors of season one which is
why i know that the process and the army
of hair and makeup people that go on
behind it um but it does make me feel a
little bit better because i got did
quite dirty by my stylist as well but
i don't know i didn't ever think that it
was unrepresentative i just thought that
i got put in a
shitty pair of swim shorts
yeah i mean whoever is working on that
end is deciding what i guess everybody
should look like
um i think that happens with dating too
we put out what we should look like and
then we meet the person in real life and
it's like we get a much accurate
picture of them
yeah
being more accurate i think sets you up
for more success
yeah i mean if you pitch yourself we
were talking about this before that um i
would love to see
um people that are in relationships that
maybe met online on tinder or whatever
go back and look at their profile the
profile of their partner when they first
met and play a game where you said okay
just how accurate was this person when
they were trying to show themselves
online you know was their
hinge or tinder profile accurately
representing them and based on what you
know now after five years of being
together and maybe marriaging kids or
whatever um
just how truthful was that and how
important is it is there a success
correlated between people that are
accurate and realistic with the way that
they portray themselves on online dating
and success long-term in relationships
or can you kind of fake it until you
make it and claim that you're
six foot five and
whatever you want to be in the world and
then once you've got people through the
door sort of change that around i
thought that'd be a really interesting
thing to do
i happen to think it the more you put
accurate pictures of yourself online
when you're dating then when you meet
the person and they see how amazing you
are in person it only adds to your
success rather than someone being
disappointed because you misrepresented
yourself online
well love island are going to be
disappointed with everything that they
do unfortunately it would seem
apparently everybody's going to be
misrepresented but
like i say it's a people get super
passionate there's an entire subculture
online now of people doing twitter
threads comparing the photos from the
press tour
media team with people's actual
instagrams and again i can't believe how
how they've done them dirty but
moving on from love island what's your
background we're talking about anxious
attachment styles today how are you
an authority in the world of attachment
styles
yeah sure so i'm a psychotherapist and i
specialize in relationships so i i'm an
imago therapist which we can get into
and i um
i really study the dynamics energy
nervous systems the types of
relationships that work well versus what
doesn't work well and what people don't
really understand that's under the
surface in terms of
how the dynamics play out and
finding a partner that fits your needs
is about knowing your attachment needs
and knowing what you're looking for i
often say it's more important than
knowing your horoscope because when you
really understand that about yourself
you can also find a partner that isn't
going to re-injure your needs but
actually be able to meet more of your
needs and knowing that up front really
kind of can set you up for success
how common is it for a relationship
therapist
coach
to look at stuff like the biology or the
neuroscience i don't hear a massive
amount of
work coming out of the relationship
coaching space talking about the
neuroscience of different people's
attachment styles and stuff like that
yeah i think dating apps should include
it the only thing is is
certain
attachment styles attract each other and
unfortunately unfortunately sometimes
the ones that really have explosive
relationships tend to attract each other
more
so you know trying to understand
attraction and why you might be
attracted to a certain person
and getting really clear on that
and looking for healthy ways in which
you can attract people who might be more
fitted for your attachment style will
set you up for success versus
chemistry from a wounded place that's
the best way i can explain it or a place
that might reinforce your your core
wounds already
what's the science behind attachment
styles
so when you're born
and you're co-regulating with your
mother and or private caregiver there's
a whole dance of interactions that go on
between you and your primary caregiver
as to how they're attending to you
and how they are seeing you and how you
learn to trust your needs are going to
get met
and depending on
your parent and this is not about blame
but your parent could be stuck in
a stress response or
maybe
nada that doesn't have the emotional iq
that is attending to you in the way that
you truly need you develop at
adaptations when you're really young in
your embedded nervous system responses
in terms of how you get your needs met
and
a belief system around relationships you
develop that felt sense so inside your
body early on and what the research
shows and it's actually really proven
it's like 80 to 90 percent is that those
embedded patterns and adaptations show
up later in your romantic life so when
you're struggling in a romantic life or
when you're in a partnership and you hit
bumps and everything like that the
adapted patterns and
the core beliefs that you had early on
actually replay themselves in your
romantic relationships later on so
knowing that ahead of time and knowing
what your needs are ahead of time and
knowing how your partner handles
conflicts and where they stand in terms
of how they see relationships
can set you up for a safer place to play
out your patterns and heal them versus
repeat and re-injure
the same patterns
what was the studies that looked at
comparing
child upbringing with attachment styles
later in life how did they do that
um it's attachment theory and
oh god there's been so much science i i
can't even specifically there's an
attachment assessment that's like 80
accurate
um there's so much science and not only
the science is so accurate so how you
developed these adaptations
highly correlates to how you show up in
your romantic relationships and there's
just been countless studies around it i
mean every therapist really understands
at the root there's an attachment
kind of wound or theory behind how you
show up in your romantic life so we we
really do work with attachment and part
of therapy is attaching to your
therapist and kind of replaying some of
these things so you re experience things
and kind of can re-heal them in that
therapeutic relationship interesting i
didn't know if it was
complete bro science or
something very very legit the first time
that i ever heard about different
attachment styles was james smith who's
a buddy of mine he was telling me about
it on the show he was explaining that he
was
uh avoidant and this is the way that it
works and and i was like oh well this
just sounds like i know a cute framework
that perhaps someone's put together what
you're saying is that it's a very robust
body of knowledge that's been replicated
and is now kind of relied on heavily in
the coaching and therapy space
yeah everything from addiction to how
you show up in your romantic life to
where you have problems in the world it
can all go back to the developmental
years and a lot of people are detached
from that because
things don't look like trauma but
developmental trauma and how you
received what was acceptable and what
wasn't acceptable and your emotion how
your parents dealt with your emotional
responses and really co-regulation which
we can get into but how well your
parents attuned to you
saw you and attended to you you develop
a trust there and that inherent trust
shows up in your relationships later but
if you didn't develop a trust there
that distrust also shows up in your
relationships later and it's a spectrum
of course but there's a very very high
correlation between early developmental
years and your romantic relationships
now
even though
the memories that you've got from then
are
well beyond something perhaps that you
may even be able to recall if it's stuff
that during developmental years i i i
think my earliest memory is maybe four
years old and it's me slipping on some
ice i don't remember the way that i was
brought up for the first four years that
i existed and i was there but
you're saying that even though this
perhaps isn't something that we can
consciously recall it's embodied how's
that working yeah it's like a felt sense
so i mean
our nervous system and a lot of what my
book talks about is the automatic
nervous system
is still being developed in womb until
about 18 months out of womb so we don't
have something called the
parasympathetic nervous part of our
nervous system fully developed our
primary caregiver is a stand-in
so for those that are listening our
ability to self-regulate
comes from our ability for our parent to
help us co-regulate self-soothe us early
on you outsource your
regulation to the caregiver for the
first 18 months of life yes
yeah the more they can attune and help
soothe you the more you build the brain
waves or the pathways for
self-regulation later on and the more
you learn to trust that person it's it's
like a paradox it's like the more you
can depend on your primary caregiver in
a healthy way
the more you can develop
as an adult the more you have
self-regulation as adult the more that
you can trust your partner as an adult
the less you can depend and and again
this happens subconsciously and this
happens really early on
you might
feel like
the shoe is going to drop or that you
know you're not going to get your needs
met or you might become hyper vigilant
or like you said your friend becomes
avoidant and their core belief is that
their needs aren't going to get met for
whatever reason that relationships
aren't really as important or they can't
trust is easier and it does come down to
trust on both sides of insecure
attachment
because if you didn't develop that
inherent trust early on
your trust in getting your needs met in
your relationships later on can be very
challenging
what age does
imprinting of attachment style start to
drop off
so there's
there's different wounding or different
stages at every
level and i would say that you can have
an experience later on
that still impact impacts you but the
earlier the experience the bigger the
impact no way
yeah
so those formative like moments of
womb you you're you're building your
nervous system while you're in womb with
your prime with your mother
so depending on her nervous system and
how stressed out she is you're still
developing parts of your body your brain
your system is still developing and then
when you come out you're not fully
developed
yet either so you're still developing
those systems and so if she's like my
mother um
struggled from postpartum depression and
a little bit of anxiety and she was
constantly worried about me
and my father was a little bit more
absent so i you internalize those
systems and and when i say a felt sense
you internalize this felt sense of your
primary caregivers and they live
embedded in your body and so when you
meet someone who reminds you of a
primary caregiver there can be a
familiarity there that's actually an
attraction
and so imago or some people think you
can be
drawn to these people
trying to resolve
your attachment issues through people
who represent some qualities that are
similar from your primary caregivers and
unconsciously what happens is sometimes
you re-injure
things because you pick people who can't
provide you the safety
or their
ability to regulate isn't
an ability to help you regulate because
there's a familiarity there yeah that
makes sense absolutely i mean the fact
that
when you grow up you look for patterns
of love that are familiar to you from
when you were a kid
and
the patterns don't even show up until
you the attachment really takes place
which is not always in the beginning of
the relationship but if you grew up
without a lot of attunement and
co-regulation and
not feeling that special when you meet
someone who quote unquote love bombs you
or makes you feel really special the
neural chemicals that are released early
on in the relationship are extra potent
because your brain didn't receive them
as a baby so now you're really like oh i
feel really special i'm getting my needs
met and then the relationship evolves
and attachment takes place and um fear
comes up and core wounds come up and
dysregulation comes up and then that's
where we can get into a little bit of
trouble with our partners as
as the relationship kind of involves
people always say oh i started out and
it was perfect and it was wonderful and
relationships are supposed to bring up
our wounding and they do get we have
something called a rupture and repair so
we're supposed to get into conflict and
how we get into conflict and how we get
back into connection
it's not that conflict doesn't happen
and with our primary caregiver
it's not that conflict doesn't happen we
cry for help we cry for our needs if our
partner or a parent can attune to that
we learn that our needs can get met
but if they aren't really attuned to
that
then we start to learn that our needs
aren't going to get met all the time or
not at all and so we start to form these
nervous system responses that then
repeat themselves in our romantic
relationships have you looked at whether
or not attachment style is heritable
whether there's a genetic component in
here
i think there is a genetic
component for sure um
it's very hard nature versus nurture
especially especially is whatever is the
heritable gene is probably behaviorally
showing up in the parent so how are you
going to separate out what is gene from
you would need to find a parent that had
the gene for anxious but was
behaving oh
secure
in order to then be able to say okay
well how much gets passed on and then
what's up bring yeah i imagine this is a
particularly difficult
um
study to do
well and then it's intergenerational
so if your parent was a little bit more
anxious there was a good chance that
their parent was a little bit more
anxious because our brain mirrors
and is developed by our parents so in
those it's called mirror neurons and
residency circuits so our brain is
developing in in mirroring our primary
caregivers so
yeah it's intergenerational in that it
gets passed down that way and that way
it's not our parents fault either they
are showing up in the way that they can
show up and they have stressors and they
have things that happen in their life
that cause them to not be attuning in a
way that we need because they didn't get
proper attunement or maybe something
major was going on in their life like my
mom was going through a divorce so i'm
sure her system was locked up in a
couple different you know nervous system
responses that my system was picking up
if a baby senses fear in another they
absorb that because we're one energetic
unit so we take in our parents we
internalize them for better or worse we
also internalize the good things too
it's not just the fear responses we take
on the good things too so sometimes when
we attract a partner it's not just it's
the positive and negative qualities of
that person that pull us in so there can
be a lot of positive qualities too that
remind us of our primary caregivers that
we're attracted to as well how conscious
or subconscious is this can you think
your way out of an attachment style
um you can't think your way out of
attachment style but i talk about it in
my book you can earn your way to earn
security and for people who are
anxiously attached
the missing link is usually
self-regulation or co-regulation and
then they can't self-soothe later on so
they're always looking for their partner
to help them feel safe and help them
regulate because they didn't develop
that
those pathways so well when they were
younger so you can work towards earn
security through your partner and
through many relationships once you
start to become aware and i would say
most people aren't 100 aware which is
why i want to get this information out
there because if you have the same
patterns repeating over and over and
over again there's a good chance you can
repair that and it might not always be
in your romantic relationship and when
you do repair it you might be attracted
to somebody different
what's the big red pill that everybody
needs to understand about anxious
attachment then let's say that somebody
hasn't heard of attachment styles before
they don't know what they are they don't
know what they are in terms of
categories and stuff like that how does
someone know if they're anxiously
attached
so i mean codependency is like a
buzzword
so uh someone who is hyper vigilant of
their partner's needs and they're able
to track their partner more than they
track themselves they tend to
self-abandon
someone who
fears disconnection or feels
uncomfortable when their partner pulls
away
if their partner shuts down it can
activate an avalanche inside of them
because that form of disconnection is so
painful
um someone who
sometimes is
insecure or has a
a sense of not good enough inside
because there's that secure base is not
there so i'm not enough and tends to
jump to the conclusion that i did
something wrong
someone who over extends themselves in
relationship to get love like meaning i
have to do something or i have to make
this person happy in order to get them
to love me
these are all ways in which you can tell
you have a more anxious base
i think most importantly when your
partner shuts down how do you respond
anxious people's energy tends to expand
so when you're a baby when you're not
getting your needs met you cry and then
when you're not getting your needs met
again you cry and etc etc until
full-blown rage happens
and this is actually a very normal
response to getting our needs met is
that we we go down this ladder
then when you're an adult and you're not
getting your needs met in this
relationship you're either scared of
conflict so you're suffering deep inside
because you don't want to upset this
person because abandonment could be
around the corner or you slip into rage
because you try to connect and you try
to connect and you try to connect and
that person is just not available
because they're locked in some kind of
response that's making them kind of
frozen or stuck or or avoidant
and so
what happens in your body is is pretty
intense
and so i really explain
the nervous system and what happens in
your body is actually your body's
survival mechanisms acting up in terms
of trying to get you back into
connection because our biological
imperative is to be in connection and
when we're in disconnection we sense it
in our bodies
depending on the degree of it like if a
partner goes blank on you or frozen it
can feel really really scary
an example is that my dad struggled with
some substance abuse growing up
so if my partner checks out at all
and it's not his fault
i my whole system lights up and i know
that he's not doing this to me i know
there's a partner a part of me a younger
part of me that's sensing this is not
safe because he's gone
and that's what i felt as a child like
he's just not there there's something
called the blank stare where you can
look at someone and they're just not
attuning to you and they're not really
connecting to you they're just kind of
checked out that's a very painful
experience and they've done numerous
studies on that that's actually
as painful as physical pain when you
feel like your primary caregiver is not
there
you're literally scared or terrified and
then when your partner checks out the
same terror can come up in those
sensations in your body so starting to
notice you know what happens inside of
me when my partner shuts down or goes
away and is it explosive in my body is
letting you know there are some
developmental things that need to be
healed
what's going on
biologically or neurologically in an
anxious person versus someone else that
wants the cascade that's happening
that's causing that to occur
sympathetic arousal so you know it's
like fight flight free spawn even a
dorsal shutdown so it's when your heart
usually you go into fight because
usually an anxious person learns if i
get louder or if i try to connect
they're always trying to connect i want
to get my partner closer so i can feel
safe if i can get them closer then i
feel safe if they go further away then
the abandonment gets
kicked up sometimes we're not even
conscious of this but um
if you notice that you're trying to get
your partner closer you're always trying
to get back into connection you're
always saying you're sorry
you're starting to try to
not manipulate that's the wrong word
because it's an adaptive strategy but
you're trying to keep your partner close
so that you don't have to feel those
painful feelings of disconnection and by
the way you don't have to be anxious if
your partner disconnects it's painful it
can be very painful and so the varying
degree will let you know
is this something that happened really
young or is it just really painful
because the person i love is shutting
down on me and i don't know
why and i want to know why and can i
respect that they're shutting down and
they will come back
or when they shut down do i feel like
they're
abandoning me forever and they're
they're never coming back and so that's
where you can kind of see the fear can
get so escalated
have you considered why this is adaptive
why is it
that the attachment style that you learn
from your caregiver during infancy when
you grow up
why is it that
that
would be something that would be useful
or evolutionarily adaptive for you to
then try and replicate in later life is
this because
our tribe is going to be sufficiently
small that this might be a culture
that's going on over have you have you
thought about why this might happen
adapted
well adaptively it's it's all about our
nervous system and our nervous system
adapts um
fight flight free so we have something
called neuroreception
and so um stephen so it's like okay it's
like if you and i were in relationship
and
um
i care deeply about you and you we have
inner and outer cues that are constantly
scanning our environment for safety or
threat
and your cues might be different than my
cues but depending on our earlier
experiences this happens on a
subconscious level if you roll your eyes
or pick up your phone right now or do
something it can cue me
that this isn't safe or my partner's not
with me we're always looking for are you
with me
will you not judge me will you you know
be attuned to me and
so these neurosceptic this neuro ception
of safety and threat and danger we're
doing on a subconscious level we're
constantly scanning our environment is
this safe and so our partner who we
attach to very very deeply can do
something very very small
that can cue our nervous system like oh
this is familiar i don't know what about
it is familiar but this feels familiar
and this feels very scary
and so our system shifts into a survival
mode
and for a lot of anxious people this is
a sympathetic response not always
sometimes it's a shutdown response but
more often than not it's an expansion of
energy of like i need to get to i need
to get back into connection and whatever
that means if it's apologizing or
getting angry
we expand our energy and so we try to
get back into connection because that
cue and it can be such a small cue and
this is where couples get into trouble
because
it can literally be pick up my phone and
i'm looking at my phone and i'm not
connecting with you that can cue so much
pain inside the other person
and maybe the person is just picking up
their phone and there's no big deal or
maybe that person's actually avoiding
you
and they're not able to connect for
their own reasons of fear of intimacy or
what's going on for them or what's being
pulled out them pulling them outside of
the relationship but how you are cued on
this neuroseption level can lead to the
cascade of
survival
strategies to get back into connection
and anxiously attached people are they
have more new reception is that right to
say more the higher degree of new
reception i would say their amygdala is
primed for abandonment so they're going
to get cued if the wind blows in the
direction of abandonment and this is not
their fault they really don't want to
really experience that again
so little things and some of the cues
are off that's the thing is sometimes
your partner's just doing something but
the assumption sometimes from someone
who's anxiously attached is the negative
like oh they don't love me they must not
care right so the q then
the body
responds way faster than the brain
eighty percent of the information is
sent up so our body picks up on these
cues and then our brain makes up a story
of why this person doesn't care why are
they not with me
they don't love me we can go down this
whole avalanche of um
you know making up a story because our
body is feeling these since
these intense sensations in that moment
what's the difference between
dealing with men and dealing with women
when it comes to anxious attachment
that's a good question um
i would say
there's a stereotype that women might be
more anxiously attached and men might be
more avoidant but that's not true
there might be a higher percentage
of women
that are more anxious and then and there
is a higher percentage that women
struggle with this but men struggle with
it too
um
i think women it's more okay for us to
be emotionally expressive
so we're gonna expand the energy and
show it emotionally men might expand the
energy and show it in anger
so they might show up if they have
anxious attachment and even more anger
or struggle with any kind of
vulnerability when it comes to really
addressing i'm scared right now or i'm
feeling lonely in this relationship it
might be harder for them to express that
because of the culture
the you know the the way in which we're
taught as the way men are taught to
express their feelings is is not allowed
as much as the way that women are but it
happens on both sides of the street and
i'm a couples counselor and
there are plenty of where the dynamic is
the the woman is a little bit more on
the avoidance side and the man is a
little bit more anxious so
yes it leans more towards women but it's
really not
rob henderson one of my friends did this
really cool analysis where he looked at
um
typical traits of masculinity in
literature um what is it that the
culture sees as a man right and kind of
that's what we invite like masculinity
isn't a thing it's
it correlates with men being men but
what does being a man mean so he looked
at what the culture was telling men that
they were supposed to be and one of the
most important things that came up
throughout all of these different
examples was control over one's emotions
the fact that you weren't supposed to be
at the mercy of your emotions this sort
of stiff upper lip stoic protect preside
provide right that was kind of the view
that you had and um
thinking about the differences in
anxious attachment
you're right it's kind of seen that
women are
more im the culture tells them that
they're more emotional that they are the
ones that are more vulnerable for sure
at least physically um but also
emotionally and then if you flip that
and you see a man that has that sort of
anxious style you think well that's
somehow him
being less of a man that somehow him
being deficient
or
defective
and that's something that he
very well may feel shame and guilt
around that he's probably going to try
and hide away and i guess as well that
this is
how it can show up in anger and perhaps
even like physical violence sometimes
that they don't
want to show the vulnerability of how
they're actually feeling so that gets
changed into something that they think
does fit
their pre-existing model of what a man's
supposed to be you know protect provide
preside isn't far away from be strong
and let this anxious
emotion out through aggression instead
of through vulnerability
yeah no absolutely and i think you know
when you're talking about anxious and
avoidant pairing because that happens a
lot
um
anxious people are attracted to what
they're missing which appears to be
stability
and independence so they tend to be a
little bit more dependent because of
their nervous system and
what's lacking is co-regulation and
self-regulation and so they tend to be
attracted to very stoic
um independent men maybe alpha you know
and so these men appear calm on the
outside but they're not actually calm if
they're avoidant they actually have a
lot of anxiety in the inside they're
just not expressing it
and um avoiding people tend to be
attracted to anxious people because
we're so lively and we're pretty
vulnerable and we're expressive
and so we're kind of attracted to the
lost parts of
each other the problem is anxious people
need to depend on their partner for
co-regulation a little bit more and
avoidant people tend to self-regulate a
little too much and they don't depend on
their partner as much so when one is
feeling scared they're reaching out for
connection and co-regulation and safety
and when the other is feeling scared
they're pulling away and trying to
self-regulate and shutting down to
manage their nervous system
so the very thing that attracted them
almost reinforce
the belief system under late night so
the belief system of an anxious person
is i'm going to be left alone i'm going
to be abandoned and so when their
avoidant person pulls away it needs to
self-regulate
that confirms that that that belief
system because when they need them the
most that person is really in a fear
response to and can't provide that
safety and then the avoidant person says
oh my god this anxious person is too
much for me i can't handle all this
emotion because they haven't dealt with
that with inside and they haven't
experienced it and their system is
freaked out and so they pull away so
both systems are stuck in like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
and it's really the automatic nervous
system is i need connection to feel safe
and i need separation in order to cool
down my system
so
and it gets even more complicated than
that but
an anxious person needs to learn how to
self-regulate or co-regulate with many
people in order to develop the
neuroplasticity to self-soothe and the
avoidant person needs to learn how to be
vulnerable
and start to co-regulate in healthy ways
and let people in
so they're very much opposites in terms
of how they adapted to survive yet
they're very drawn to each other and
there happens to be a lot of chemistry
in these types of
um relationships and they are a lot of
wounding because of the very nature and
in terms of how they adapted to survive
so it's very interesting when you start
to understand it and i go through a lot
of how you can work through these
relationships in my book because i think
once you start to understand the nervous
system on a deeper level you stop
personalizing that your person is
getting really explosive or upset you
can see they're just scared and they
want connection and you stop
personalizing oh this person's shutting
down you start realizing their system
really can't be in connection right now
they this is how they adapted and so
when you start to understand this on a
deeper level and you stop personalizing
it you start to communicate a little bit
differently in your relationship and you
can actually work through this dance um
it's just
it's a little bit harder isn't it funny
how culture kind of sees the avoidant
person like there's so much romanticism
that's put around aloofness
you know somebody who isn't always
forthcoming it's kind of seen as a
little bit more mysterious and and cool
whereas the anxious person is the one
that's overbearing
and the one that's too much and too keen
you know there's a million twitter
threads about guys that come on girls
that come on too strong too soon and how
long should i wait until i text him back
and stuff like that there it does seem
to be at least in terms of how it's seen
from the outside even if it's equally
sort of tumultuous internally that the
avoidant person comes across as the cool
one and the anxious person comes across
as the keen desperate one yes and the
needy one but if an anxious person
partners with someone who's a little bit
more secure the reassurance and the
connection is they're given and actually
the needs go down and the anxiety goes
down
but if they partner with someone who's
very avoidant
they're just shamed around their needs
and it's like happening unconsciously
and you're absolutely right i think
i think both people are really
struggling and avoiding people are
really struggling on their side of the
street too and they can be seen as the
bad one or the narcissistic one which is
not the case at all narcissism and
avoidant attachment are two very
different things but because they can
withdraw and disconnect and at times
feel cold
they can get labeled as narcissistic
when in in reality they're suffering and
that's how they're dealing but they
really want connection as well and
they're struggling with that just as
much and so they get a bad rap
on both sides and i think the anxious
person seems as too needy and i can't
stand that word but it's truly not the
case if they can feel safe in getting
their needs met the need for connection
or the neediness quote-unquote neediness
i can't stand that word but it goes down
what do you do what do you not like
about needy
because we all have needs and a lot of
the neediness is you're seeing the fear
that their needs aren't going to get met
it's not even that they're needy it's
that they're scared
there's a little bit of fear and they
just need a little bit of reassurance
you give an anxious person just a little
reassurance
and their whole system calms down and
that that quote-unquote needy energy
shifts to a calmer place
if you can kind of just help them a
little in those scared moments because
they've worked so hard to maintain
connection
and they live in the sense that the shoe
is going to drop all the time so the
more reassurance you can give them
the more they have permission to be
themselves and the less of that drive
and that fear goes down so it's like we
want to meet them rather than shame them
rather than trying to fix your anxious
attachment should people not just get a
partner that fixes the attachment style
on their behalf like can't anxiously
attach people just find someone very
loving and compassionate and reassuring
and then the anxious attachment doesn't
matter anymore i love that question so
yes and no
um your patterns are going to show up
with anyone but there will be more
forgiving relationships for you to work
through your patterns than others so if
you pick someone who's a little bit more
secure yes your patterns are going to
show up but they're going to get more
likely get healed because that your
anxiety isn't going to set an animal
lunch off in their nervous system and
they're going to be able to meet you
if you pick someone who's really anxious
where you're in you're you're like so
basically if i'm in a sympathetic state
i'm gonna signal that to you
unconsciously and you're gonna read that
in your system and if you're more
avoidant that's gonna scare you
unconsciously you're to run in the other
direction you're going to flee
so if you pick someone who's less likely
to flee
and can be in your anxiety with you
there's more opportunity to heal but
it's not that your
patterns go away it's that
um attachment is a two-way street
and depending on who you attach with and
how the patterns play out between the
two of you in that relationship gives
you more of a safe haven to work through
your patterns it's not that your
patterns go away
does that make sense yeah yeah it does
it's very interesting um
okay so
you've mentioned that the fact that
being in a relationship allows you to
heal some of the wounds
are you does that mean that it's very
difficult to
heal attachment styles on your own is
this something that can't be done in
isolation
another really great question um
healing happens in relationship but the
relationship doesn't have to be a
romantic partner
so let's say you are experiencing a lot
of pain in your romantic partner you can
bring that pain to a therapist or a
coach or even a non-judgmental friend
stop projecting it all onto your partner
and start to trace the sensations back
and start to see that this is earlier
wounding inside of you
and so you don't need to heal in your
partnership but you do need to bring the
pain to someone that can help you
understand its deeper roots
hold it with you
you know make sense of it a lot of what
i see is that people get
angry in their relationship and hurt it
in a relationship and then they call a
friend and then that friend pours more
gasoline on the relationship by saying
oh this person's a bad person and look
what they're doing to you rather than
saying
i wonder what they're bringing up inside
of you
if the sensations are big we know it's
developmental trauma
have you felt this way before and maybe
you're not even connected to the way
that you might have felt this before but
if your nervous system is responding in
a fight flight freeze response there's a
good chance you felt this way before and
you're not even conscious of it let's
say that someone has a friend that keeps
on ringing them
and saying that their relationship is
causing them to feel in this anxious way
and you're that friend what are some of
the things that you should tell the
person that's ringing you when they ring
you up
or questions that you should ask them
questions or just
validate okay i understand this is
really really scary for you
i want to hold this space let's breathe
together let's co-regulate let's not
talk about how bad your partner is
let me just have my system recognize
that i'm here with you is it better to
do this in person if you're a friend
that's trying to calm somebody else down
or is can this effectively be done over
the phone
um so when we talk about co-regulation
the best is in person because eye
contact is really great but
co-regulation happens in tone
and i felt sense that this person is
here with me i'm not alone and a lot of
what we want to do as a society is to
fix that person we don't want to see
someone we care about suffering
but it's not in the fixing because if we
fix that person or come up with a
solution we're not being with the
anxiety anxiety is a protector
we want to hold space
for our friend and say oh i see that
you're really uncomfortable right now
this must be really hard for you i'm
here for you right now the truth is if
we're in a dysregulated place
the only system that we have control
over in that moment is our respiratory
system
so if we can breathe a little bit deeper
particularly on the exhales we can trick
our brain brain back into safety and if
our friend can say okay our partner is
not completely doing this to us but it's
reacting or causing a reaction inside of
our body how do i help my friend just
calm down and get back into a safe place
which is not focusing on the story
just focusing on he i'm with you
i hear this is really scary let's be in
this together
i'm not going to try to fix you
it's about being with that anxiety in a
new way because remember that
big dysregulation is primal so there's a
good chance a primary caregiver wasn't
there to soothe
so really about soothing is about being
with it's about holding the sensation
rather than fixing the sensation
that's how you deal with a friend let's
say that you're in a relationship with
somebody and you're arguing about
something that's going on and you're
dealing with anxious attachment yourself
what are some of the ways that you
should communicate more effectively if
it's you and your partner so if your
partner is
okay with your anxiety instead of
getting angry with them you start to
verbalize that you're feeling really
disregulated and that you don't want to
fight is there a way that you can say
that without saying disregulated they
might not know what you're talking about
um you're feeling really anxious and
scared
and you're feeling um you're not really
sure why maybe because you're out of
connection and you just need them to sit
down if they're capable they're avoidant
they might not be capable sit down and
and be next to you so that you can get
your system back into what we call
ventral eventual state of connection
what's that
so when i talk about evolution there's
um dorsal shut down it's when you freeze
and really your system shuts down and
prepares for for death it's like a
reptilian way of dealing with fear and
then there's sympathetic which is fight
flight run you're activated and then our
highest form of evolution in steven
porge's um coinness and polyvagal is
eventual ventral connection and that's
when you and i are making eye contact
and we're open
and we feel safe
and we're in this you know we're cued
towards each other which we are right
now and we're really attuning that's
really where um we want to be and that's
our highest evolution in terms of social
connection
and that's where the best things happen
but throughout the day and throughout
our relationships we shift into
different states we're just not even
aware of it but if we can and we realize
we're not in this open place and
sometimes our thoughts can tell us all
of a sudden our partner becomes our
enemy and look at what they're doing i
call it case building we're case
building against them okay we've shifted
into a sympathetic fight mode we're not
feeling safety anymore we need to feel
safe in our relationships so we might
not be aware of what cued us but if our
partner can sit down and just be with us
you know attune to us and just kind of
hold us or be next to us our system
might go back into eventual place and
that's when we can get back into
connection
sometimes if our partner is causing us
the pain we need to separate ourselves
and call another who's not going to pour
gasoline on it or find other ways of
self-soothing not everybody you know the
best i think is co-regulation but there
might be hey my partner's on the same
team but my system's being activated and
i'm case building right now how can i
pull myself away and remind myself that
my partner does love me
and come back to the table where i'm
calmer and i can start to explain to my
partner what's going on inside of me
versus what they did to me
because our partners bring up our own
work and it's not many people get stuck
in the blame
and on myself included look at what you
did to me or you know you're abandoning
me or you don't care about me you want
to get out of that kind of black and
white thinking and start to explain wow
my system's feeling really unsafe right
now i'm feeling escalated i want to
fight and i know that's my nervous
system in response and so i want to try
to de-escalate my nervous system back
into like a place of safety and
connection so we can talk about what's
going on inside of ourselves reach some
empathy and understanding
that um
we can get back into connection because
essentially that's all what we want our
biological imperative is to get back
into connection so if you know that
you're escalating you'll want to find
ways to either pull away
self-soothe or co-regulate with someone
who help you calm down rather than
pouring more gasoline onto this
feeling of sensation that can be
unbearable going on inside of you
what are some of the practical ways that
somebody that deals with anxious
attachment and may have this sort of
flood of emotions due to something
that's occurred maybe they can remember
what it was that happened or maybe it's
something that's subconscious that they
just happen to have noticed you
mentioned breath work practices earlier
on
what are those and what are any of the
other strategies that you could give
someone to try and bring themselves back
online
i mean i think the most important thing
is awareness first first and foremost i
think most people aren't even aware that
they're in an activated state so you can
tell your heart rates you're starting to
i mean i can you can go zero to 100
pretty fast
and so you and it's very easy to engage
because you want to fight to get back
into connection ironically the fighting
will put you more disconnection but you
we want to sense start to become really
aware of your nervous system so that's
the first step
then there's several different things i
mean like i said breathing and i hate to
be the cliche therapist who's like oh
breathing but it's actually the
escalations because your brain is now
thinking like
cyber tooth bear is coming at you or
that you're in danger right and we live
in these states all the time but your
respiratory system your brain your body
is much smarter than your brain your
brain's going to make up a story of the
here and now that's pretty probably not
accurate but your respiratory system can
cue your brain back into safety so you
know box breathing
extending your exhales having a mantra
like i like to say inhale exhale to get
out of the story and give my mind
something to do when you say box
breathing you mean
uh inhale for a count hold for a count
exhale for a count and hold at the
bottom of her account and that all stays
the same
yeah and i really extending your exhale
um
is more of a cue to safety
so because when we're anxious our
breathing changes and when we're
sympathetic it becomes shorter and more
erratic and so if you can start to
extend the exhale part of your breathing
i know it sounds crazy but you're gonna
down regulate your system
and so breathing is a great tool um
how long would you say
would be a good sort of effective dose
for somebody to do if they wanted to
have a little routine to rely on
you know honestly a few minutes of that
breathing you can check in with your
system you are already gonna see i also
say like if you're in a committed
relationship having a mantra
my partner is on the same team as me
they're hurting as well they're not
trying to cause this hurt on me even if
i want to believe that and again going
back to inhale and exhale don't feed the
story
whatever you do don't feed the story at
that time
like oh my partner doesn't care about me
or look what they did get out of the
store if you're in an activated state
and get your body back into a calm place
and try to remember that you're on the
same team
you're on the same team you know because
it's very easy to get into that fight
mode and i think
everyone's guilty of it myself included
and there'll be days when you're more
resourced and you're like oh i'm in an
activated state let me pull myself away
and get myself to deactivate myself and
if you're with someone
who's able to say
to you this is really important let's
take a little bit of space and come back
to the table at this time because
remember anxious people feel like in
that moment they'll never get back into
connection
so giving them a time and place as to
you know right after dinner or give it
let's take a break for an hour remember
i love you let's let's cool down or you
tell your partner that and you take the
space and you come back and you share
from a place of what's going on inside
of you you share from a vulnerable place
not like you did this you did not not
from blame or projection but from a
place of i got really scared or my heart
rate started to escalate or i really
wanted to fight with you and so my
defense mechanisms were up and so that's
my nervous system my archaic you know my
sense of survival was feeling threatened
in that moment so it really comes down
to awareness and some of those tools
sometimes you can call a friend
but again or a therapist but you need to
know that that person isn't
on one side of the relationship they're
more they're holding space for your
nervous system and helping you just get
back to a place of calm
rather than often people take on anger
for you because they don't want to see
you you know hurting
but really you want that friend to be
like i know you love your partner and i
know this feels horrible right now but
let's just be with this horribleness for
a while you're not alone in it call a
friend and help you de-escalate and if
your partner has the ability to help you
in those moments your partner is a great
resource if they are capable of being
that person for you
more often than not they're also
struggling which is why you're in the
fight
what about
longer term deprogramming of anxious
attachment styles this is how we deal
with it in the moment something's arisen
we've got
box breathing extended exhales we've got
call somebody that's just going to hold
space we've got don't continue to feed
the narrative don't pour gasoline on the
fire and
create certainty around the next point
at which we're perhaps going to sort of
readdress this or come back to the
conversation with our partner
how does this
fix anxious attachment
over the longer term or what are the
ways to fix anxious attachment over the
longer term
well it's a very good question and it's
probably a pretty deep question but um
and i do go over a lot of different ways
in which you can work towards earn
security in the book
when you're young you internalize your
primary caregivers
and so if they were anxious or absent
there is a part of your psyche that is
going to that resource
when you become an adult you can
internalize
healthy people healthier
more nurturing people into your inner
community
so if you are my therapist and you are
tuning to me and you seem loving and
caring and kind and i can show more of
my parts to you
when i'm not around you
i can start to access your essence
anyway
and so this is what a baby does when
they're secure and they're not around
their primary caregivers they still feel
an inherent sense of their parents
within them they feel the essence of
security
so if you didn't get that that's picking
people now in your life as an adult
that you can spend enough time with and
your nervous system starts to recognize
they are attuning to me they do care
they're not judgmental they're accepting
me for who i am and when i experience
that enough i internalize that person
inside and i also can tell when this is
happening with a client because they'll
be going through a really hard time and
sometimes they'll need to call me in the
moment because i'm that person or
sometimes they can be like if jessica
was in the room
what would that feel like
what would she say to me
and like my amazing experience of that
recently and this is how you can tell
you really weren't
working your way towards insecurity is
that when you're really digressing you
can start to think about all the people
who care about you
and all the people who love you can
actually access that
in a regressed state
and you can start to say this is an ego
state of mind that is regressing and
it's old and it's a wound
but there's so many people who care
about me right now i'm not alone and you
can feel into that and you can access
those people as an internal resource and
again this is a missing link in your
developmental years so it's a very
i mean if you're listening it might be a
hard concept to grasp but if you can
think of the one most nurturing person
in your life if you had one
if you can access that memory and the
felt sense of being around that person
when you become an adult you can start
to access that more and more and more
and more and that's where you're
building neuroplasticity
it's actually in the
re-internalization of healthy people
and the
re-experiencing of these dysregulated
moments in the presence of safety and
healthy people that we rewire our brain
towards more earned security
how much of this
is how important is it to go back
through past traumas versus just moving
forward and going through things that
are good for us now because it seems
like i i'm not right now i'm in the uk
but i'm going back to austin in two days
time and the word trauma
is like the buzzword of every sauna chat
that i hear at some of the sort of
psychedelic places that i go to and
everyone's a trauma healer everybody's
accessing past trauma through
psychedelic drugs or through breath work
or through somatic practices or sound
baths or ketamine psychotherapy or
whatever um
how important in your experience is it
for people to revisit old traumas versus
looking forward and doing things with
new situations and trying to create new
patterns
you know it's a it's a good question
because i don't want the listeners to
think that they have to relive all their
past traumas and it's it's not a black
and white answer if things are coming up
we want to get in touch with the origin
of it and if things aren't coming up we
don't need to get in touch with the
origin of it and things unfold as they
should unfold but i think it's about the
awareness of if this intensity is coming
up inside of my body there's a history
here and the more i connect it back to
the origin the more integration in my
brain happens
so there's no quick fix
but and there's no you don't need to
dive into all your quote unquote trauma
you need to meet
yourself moment to moment
with what's showing up with tenderness
and care and awareness that this might
be a little bit older than you think and
only that you don't need to meet the
moments of your life and your the safety
in which you feel things and the safety
or the way in which things show up in
your life is what needs to be met
in that moment so it's it's
you know a lot of people wanna heal
their trauma overnight but it's really a
slowing down
and meeting what is somatically
and being more conscious of what is in
the moment here and now in the summit in
your body
in in a tender compassionate way
that leads to integration in your brain
i don't know if that answers your
question but i know everybody's what
i've got in my head is i'm always a
little bit
i've always got a little bit of ick or
just distrust i think
when people hop on too much about trauma
about past trauma and i really been
trying to work out what it is
i think it feels to me a little bit like
um
people that have got an injury saying
that the chiropractor that can like snap
their back or crack their bones and
that's going to fix the misalignment
into place it's like that's a very acute
solution to a problem which is systemic
and ingrained it's ingrained in the way
you move it's ingrained in the posture
it's in the way that your bones that sit
around the structure the muscles that
sit around the structure that is your
bones it's the way that they've learned
to move over time and it's just always
felt a little bit to me like
one
significant moment that fixes trauma
seems really unrealistic because
i understand how myelin gets laid down
in the brain it's tons and tons and tons
of different pathways so what are you
telling me you've managed to turn all of
those pathways off you don't get to cut
off pathways that's not a thing those
pathways are there for life you just get
to lay new pathways that are going to be
more easy for you to access than those
ones and i think that's why
people that have said that
one
amazing psychedelic trip or one
very meaningful meditation session or
whatever sort of healed and fixed my
trauma um
it might be placebo but it doesn't seem
to me like it can actually structurally
be making those sorts of changes in the
brain i think that's why i've got a
little bit of hesitation around the
trauma stuff
yeah let me let me explain that a little
bit better um so a a plant medicine or
something like that it could be a
doorway in
and what i mean is it could get you out
of some of your thinking and give you a
new um
observer of your own mind but the way
neural
pathways are formed in our brain it's
like if your house was across the street
from me
and
it snowed a lot and anxiety was my
protector
i'm gonna have a well-worn path to your
house i'm gonna walk to your house every
day and that path is gonna be well worn
and that might be anxiety
as i start to heal and expand my window
of tolerance i learn there might be
other paths
and i start to take other paths which
are harder because they're not as well
worn
more effortful more deliberate more
intentional yeah and maybe
a lightbulb moment went off where i
found out oh my god there's a
possibility of another pathway
it doesn't mean that that pathway is
easier
and it doesn't mean that that's the
pathway we're going to choose every day
it means the more we practice that
pathway the more that becomes an option
if enough stressors happen in my life i
might go to anxiety because that's the
most well-worn pathway but over time and
with
nurturing and care and and i think some
of these more these bigger experiences
using plant medicine which i actually
haven't personally really experienced
myself but i think they open the door to
possibility
but they're not the solution they're
just opening the door to possibility and
people tend to go back and back and back
and not integrate it at all in my
experience
but if they can open the possibility
that i've been using this one pathway
and there is another pathway or there is
another experience that i did experience
so i know there's another reality out
there that exists
we can start to form the new neural
pathways but we have to practice those
pathways and we also have to give
ourselves compassion when we use the old
pathways because they're well worn so
building new plasticity is is about and
those some of those things are about
learning new possibilities and then
practicing those new possibilities with
an observer mind if we are resourced in
that moment if we're too regressed or
too much stress has come into our life
we will go to our default which is a
protection
and we will go to the pathway of least
resistance but if we continue to learn
new ways to get to that person's house
that may be the snow and eventually
those pathways get that's the best way i
can describe it does that make sense you
nailed it you absolutely nailed it i
think that one of the problems that i
had was that it was so
it sounds like when people talk about
healing trauma
not like
it showed me that there is another
alternative to this particular pattern
of behavior that i can do that may be
better for me than that one the way that
it's put across the way that a lot of
people talk about it is that
that trauma's now gone i had this sort
of single formative experience which is
completely fake you understand what i
mean right like that's the sort of
language that people use around it and i
think that that's where the it came from
that i knew
inherently that look it's wrapped up be
very careful with that i'd be very very
careful with that listen i can't speak
on that because i haven't experienced
that myself in my own me neither maybe
maybe we're both talking out of our ass
and maybe you take the right dose of
ayahuasca in the right situation and it
completely fixes everything and i don't
know but it doesn't seem likely
i think i think the one thing it could
do is open your mind to other
possibilities that your mind was so
stuck in these repetitive pathways and
now you know there's another way to
experience the world but you got to
access that naturally because if your
only way to access it is through like
these
you know ayahuasca spend the rest of
your life on drugs in a desperate
attempt to try and have a good
attachment style i'm not against them
i'm again i'm for them showing you
possibilities but true healing or my
opinion healing happens slowly
organically meeting things moment to
moment with the right support
being curious about your system and i
always say like we talk about somatic
work somatic work is the same sensation
in your body when you can meet what is
and slow down you create space
and when you create space you are being
more and more with yourself in a new way
and i feel like you don't want to flood
your system
by creating so much space that you don't
know what to do it's about meeting what
is and tending to that and as you start
to meet what is in the safety of others
more and more implicit memories more and
more quote-unquote trauma surfaces and
we can meet more and more of it but it
happens organically
and it happens in my opinion in in a way
that unfolds where your system can
handle it
and so it's a process that i wish we
could snap our fingers who wants to live
through uncomfortable sensations again
but it's actually being with those
uncomfortable sensations in new ways
that prevents you from avoiding or
having behaviors that have you
unconsciously avoid those sensations in
the first place so for an anxious person
it's about being with the sensations of
feeling left or abandoned in the
presence of safety more and more so that
those sensations don't freak you out as
much
and your system is building what we call
a window of tolerance for them
and you can tell this is happening when
you're going through an experience
that's incredibly painful and you have
the awareness of what you're actually
going through rather than being in the
experience you become more and more an
observer and when you're an observer the
possibilities of how you respond
to those scary things that are happening
in your body expand
and now we have different choices when
we're in really scary situations and
that to me is healing and i can tell
when people are healing because it's not
that the sensations stop it's because
they have more of a tenderness towards
what's going on with them they have more
of an understanding what's going on with
them they have more choices
they're not as reactive in those
situations
so
yes those could be doorways in to other
possibilities but i don't believe
they're the end solution but
listen
i've seen some people use ketamine and
and other things and it's helped move
the needle
but it is not
the end-all solution it's like if that's
a tool for you now you need to be using
this tool sober
and starting to understand how the
needle got moved and starting to
integrate that experience sober
so that you can start to understand how
to access and what's really going on in
your brain in your body not keep going
back to that same thing and thinking
that that's actually the solution it's
just maybe a lens in which helps you see
your own process differently yeah the
fact that that's a gateway drug or um
[Music]
the sort of pebble at the top of an
avalanche or whatever that cascades down
and says look from here if you go and do
the work if you iterate if you're very
deliberate and intentional about the way
that you move forward and you do the
integration there's a term i learned um
called spiritual bypass oh god don't get
me started on that okay or spiritual
tourism um and uh
i i that's one of the things that i fear
about about sort of the the current sort
of psychedelic movement that people are
going to have these sort of mystical
peak
quasi-religious experiences and then
coming back and then going away again
it's like literally like going on
holiday to i don't know some other brain
state you go well
i'm not convinced that that's any more
awakened than somebody that hasn't done
it at all like you're not actually
changing your day-to-day experience
there's two ways to think of this
if you go to a candy store and you
experience the best candy in the whole
world
and then you come out of it
you're gonna attribute to get back into
that candy store
but if you're slowly slowly opening
yourself
in in like an organic way you're not
trying to get to some state that was
there that got you there
with an like a medicine but
if you can i mean and so there's
positive and negatives if you can say i
was in this candy store and it was
amazing and i know that's possible and
i'm going to integrate that and work
towards
accessing more and more of that state
you might be able to use it as a way to
just expand your mind that there's more
to reality than in the ingrained ways
that you lived
but i think you know in my book i have
meditations um somatic meditations and a
big part of
the meditations is not to infuse
gratitude and infuse love into yourself
it's to bring in your felt experience of
positive times
and to meet your body where it's at
not to
so
to be with your heart space whereas
where it's a heart brain it's where we
store all the pain of disconnection and
all the joy from connection in our heart
brain and it's actually a very intricate
brain there in our belly brain
score stores all the fear and our
muscles and our fascia and our body
stores a lot of memories in the tissue
so by meeting them without directing
them without trying to fix them
but with meeting yourself where you're
at
that's where the the sensations and the
history and the stored things come to
the surface and that's what you tend to
it's not about fixing or changing it's
about a being with more and more of
yourself
one of the things i've realized having
had this chat with you is
it feels like
anxious attachment
is a particularly sort of
torturous or ugly um
problem to have because it was caused
by somebody that wasn't you
in a period a lot of the time
before you can perhaps even remember it
or certainly before you were you know a
sovereign individual that could have
some sort of major influence over your
own life and then when it gets to
adulthood the vast majority of the work
that you need to do is also relying on
other people like it seems if you're a
person that likes to be a solo ranger
taipei go get a solitary you know like
workhorse
this this doesn't really lend itself to
your your skill set
tremendously well and there's a a blog
post that i really really love it's
called monk mode by illimitable man and
it basically talks about how
um
sometimes met it's a blog for men men
need to go away and and just work on
themselves and it's built on three eyes
it's like isolation introspection and
something else and i was thinking
i really like the
i really like the process of it i really
like the fact that it's talking about
becoming a sovereign individual working
on yourself developing things virtues
and working on you
and yet it plays into a narrative that
i'm seeing more and more online which is
i don't need anybody else i'm going to
do this completely on my own i'm able to
hoist the entire world on my shoulders
you know like sisyphus we have to
imagine him happy or atlas holding up
the world like these are typical
masculine archetypes that we're talking
about here
and
it seems like there are a big chunk of
things
that you just can't do
like that you can't do this on your own
the lift is just too heavy i have such
an important thing to say about that
because well and men yeah atlas and and
this whole idea and
as someone who suffered from what i call
codependency which is why i wrote the
book in the first place
um i thought i had to become super
independent
and do it on my own and for many years i
felt that way and it actually was
causing me so much harm
because wounding happens in relationship
healing happens in relationship we need
community to heal we need mirrors to
heal and i'm not saying isn't a part of
this as self-reflective
there is
but the truth is we want interdependency
which means our goal is i can depend on
you you can depend on me
you can be inherently yourself your full
self i can be inherently my full self i
trust
that you're going to respond if you care
about me
and i'm going to respond to the best of
our ability but the trust is there and
that if you know and i'm not saying
people don't go on their hero's journey
um when i first wrote this book i was
kind of like how do i help people's
self-help
when really every therapist and all the
science proves that we are meant to be
in community
um we heal in our relationship
experiences we get wounded and heal in
that
and that our relationship with self
is a relationship in itself but we can't
form a healthier relationship with self
without experiencing
a healthy relationship with another on
the outside
in order to internalize what a nice
healthy voice inside will be
so i think there is a place to go out
and
be introspective and go inside and be a
hermit absolutely
but
community and connection is how we
thrive it's biologically how we're wired
we're wired and so in america there's
this whole like culture of
you got to be independent and you got to
be self-sufficient and i i my mom was
super independent and super successful
and i bought into that and it only hurt
me
it really really only hurt me it wasn't
until i depended on the right people
that i became more interdependent more
self-sufficient and it was more able to
be myself more accepting of myself and
it was letting in that support
that actually let me feel less alone and
more myself uniquely and autonomously
myself so the paradox here is
we actually need people we need
community we need much more community
than our community offers
and this whole like you success and you
got to be on your own and put your nail
you know this whole independent culture
is hurting and and i can go into brain
development because that's really a left
brain way of being
at the very left mode do this do that
you you you better be successful on your
own it's very linear it's very
um
our right brain which we don't live
enough by is the felt sense of
interconnectedness it's the fel sense of
seeing the wholeness seeing how we are
all interconnected and connected on a
spiritual level but on a nervous system
level we're connected to our environment
we're connected to trees we're connected
to each other we don't live in a world
that supports that at all
but inherently if you look at evolution
that's how that's how we're designed
that's where ventral connection comes
it's in the safety of others it's in
safety of having the right community
around us it's not that we're
dependent in a bad way on them it's that
that healthy dependency that i got this
community that helps me be more myself
so you know i'm not knocking going away
there have been periods in my life where
i've had to go away and really go inward
but
if you're really struggling with these
types of things the truth is pulling in
the right support
is actually what's going to help you
become more and more yourself
and more accepting of yourself so
it's a little hard to watch those
messages go out because i was i want to
say i was imprinted with them too you
got to be successful you got to be on
your own you got to be a badass you got
to be selfish i coined the word self
full no you got to learn how to meet
your own needs
and know that you can meet your needs
and the meets needs of another safely in
the same universe it's not one or the
other
it's really interesting i see on the
youtube comments there will be comments
on this video that say um i don't need
anybody relationships at the suckers uh
tried it failed not bothered about
trying again like this is a very
those are protectors this is a very very
very common trope that's happening on
the internet at the moment a lot it's
almost exclusively amongst guys you've
got the mgtow movement black pill in
cell culture which probably isn't a part
of that but at the very least the men
going their own way thing like for me
it's guys that have you know
got fears and have been hurt and you
know we've just seen this amber heard
case which is you know it's right in
front of your face that you can have an
incredibly terrifying relationship from
both sides like both the guys did wrong
things but she's obviously one of those
the sort of girl that a thread on our
slash men's rights would be written
about right you know she's tried to take
the kids away she's lied about how he
was supporting them and blah blah blah
blah like that so i'm not saying that
those things don't exist my point is
that
like that is a really really prevalent
subculture online at the moment and i
want
i want to find a way to speak to those
guys and say look
my experience having met i've met over a
million people in my life right running
nightclubs a million people
very few people that are alive on the
planet right now will have met more
people than i have
that's not been my experience having
spent time around so many other humans
your experience that you have seen based
on uh highlights of the most viral
twitter and reddit threads from a very
specific type of of narrative doesn't
reflect what i've seen and
there's this kind of heroic narrative
around being able to do it on your own
about being a solo ranger that's a
sovereign individual that doesn't need
anybody else whether that's on for girls
or for guys you know like i don't need
no man strong independent boss babe or
the
solo monk modes entrepreneur that's
going to go and you know sisyphus his
way to
the end of his life
those don't seem like particularly
heroic narratives to me like when you
actually look at it you go hang on is it
more heroic for you
to just care about you for the rest of
your life like is that really the
pinnacle of what you've got to deliver
to the world this like very selfish
fast car big house but nobody else in it
except for me existence is that really
what you're what you're here to deliver
to the world
or is there a more heroic narrative
which allows you to face the things that
you're the most scared of that allows
you to enter into a relationship with
somebody either as a friendship or as a
partner
fully knowing that this could end with
you becoming hurt like that that is the
heroic narrative as far as i can see but
that's not the one that gets pushed
online
no and i mean there are people who need
less relationships than others a very
avoided person doesn't need
relationships or doesn't value
relationships in the same way but
we're biologically wired to be in
connection and i can say as a
codependent survivor or someone who has
been wounded in relationship the
pendulum is i can do this on my own
because when you've been wounded or when
you've been hurt
the natural defense is i don't want to
go there anymore that is painful and so
the narrative that comes out is i don't
need anyone and that is a form of
protection it is very lonely on that
side of the coin
and so it's okay if you're there but
once you get there and you're at the top
and you realize how lonely you are you
realize that in my personal belief life
is about heartfelt connections
and the meaning in life and the quality
of your life comes down to the
relationships in your life and
neuroscience actually proves this
and our human biology shows us that we
are wired to be in community and
connection and that we'll thrive more
and humani in in connection and it
doesn't mean that you have to have a
romantic partner per se
but that the need for connection is
inherently in us and we will we will
actually gravitate towards warm safe
connection
neuroscience shows that we gravitate
towards this so if someone's really
pushing this away
i believe that they're very wounded and
something happened and hurt them so much
that it's too scary for them to go back
into connection and for me it makes me
very sad because success is not a
measure of how big your house is or what
you have accumulated
success or how about this meaning comes
from
how we connect to others and what we
how we deepen in our life and how we
experience that and so i just think it's
a narrative that
helps people deal with pain that they
might not even be conscious of that
they're pushing people away and there's
a reason behind that and you kind of
want to get curious and some people need
to get to the top of the mountain of
success and realize it's kind of lonely
up there sometimes that's your path
but
biologically speaking neurobiologically
speaking how we've developed as humans
all point to
we need connection connection is a
biological imperative we thrive the most
as an individual
when we're supported in community and so
for whatever that's worth
you know i hope that more people are
move towards the right felt sense of
interconnectedness and that that we all
need each other and that we're all more
alike than we're different and move in
the direction of community and the
importance of community and having that
deep connection with another because i
really truly believe that's what gives
meaning to life
jessica baum ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do and check you out
online where should they go
well i'm jessica baum lmhc is my
instagram
and yeah i wrote this book and
i'm just really excited to offer it to
the world anxiously attached becoming
more secure in life and love and you can
put jessica baum lmhc into um the
computer my company name is beselful.com
that's my coaching company i have like
five therapists who are trained with me
and we work on relational issues on all
aspects
and so yeah that's how you can find me
amazing jessica i appreciate you thank
you
i appreciate you so much too what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you